this morning crowds are gathering at
Kennedy Space Center to mark the 50th
anniversary of historic Apollo 11 launch
let's go back to Tony to copal near
launch pad 39a Tony what's the move
there right now
excitement wonder it's a beautiful
morning as it was the morning of that
launch 50 years ago the actual moonwalk
by the way happened 50 years ago this
coming Saturday half a century later
though historians tend to agree it still
stands as perhaps humanity's greatest
achievement to date before any steps
could be taken here one giant leap had
to be made on earth it's going to be a
journey certainly for the history books
and it all started with a push Russia
launched the first person into space in
1961 inspiring America to reach further
we choose to go to the moon and to get
there what we needed is one of these the
Saturn 5 rocket which was n is the most
powerful rocket ever built here at the
apollo saturn v center you get a sense
of its sheer size 6 million pounds when
fueled for liftoff with enough power to
drive the average car around the world
800 times on the morning of July 16th
1969 it commanded the world's attention
more than a million people reportedly
traveled to see it this is CBS news
color coverage a man on the moon
millions more tuned in the epic journey
of Apollo 11
as Neil Armstrong Buzz Aldrin and
Michael Collins headed out for another
world so it is now before they go is
their gleaming vehicle sits poised and
peaceful out there behind me on pad 39a
that there is time if only briefly in
this busy morning to think of those
three men and the burdens and the hopes
that they carry on behalf of all mankind
and at 9:32 a.m. ignition sequence start
the sky it seemed was no longer the limp
liftoff we have a liftoff 32 minutes
past the hour liftoff on Apollo 11 and
later this morning we'll have a live
special report to mark the exact moment
fifty years ago when Apollo 11 lifted
off looking looking forward to that Tony
thank you